j'accueille maintenant Stéphane Guillon
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
arrêtez
[Applaudissements]
les secondes viens
parce que j'ai voulu le métro anglais
[Applaudissements]
la semaine de Lyon
quoi de neuf alors une toute petite
revue de presse aujourd'hui Thierry
service minimum je rappelle que depuis
l'affaire l'énergie les chroniqueurs
sont en grève
notre principal revendications faire
notre chronique équipée d'un collier mou
pour parer à tous risques de
strangulation super merci beaucoup
allez c'est un entier en entier
trembleur oui alors c'est très moche
on a l'air d'un con mais c'est la survie
d'une profession qui est en jeu
salut on repassage le très beau geste de
Thierry Ardisson qui remplace Louise
Bourgoin chez Michel Denisot c'est la
première fois qu'un animateur accepte un
boulot de chroniqueurs afin d'en évaluer
les risques au nom de tous mes collègues
Thierry merci
merci beaucoup
les chroniqueurs subissent des bizutages
insensés pour travailler dans une
émission de Stéphane Bern Jean-Pierre
Mocky a dû déclarer Berne un physique de
cinéma
heureusement il y a aussi de beaux
gestes cette semaine Thierry Beccaro
reconnaît qu'il doit beaucoup à William
Leymergie
enfin il va se faire étrangler
heureusement il y a aussi de beau gestes
cette semaine Thierry Beccaro reconnaît
qu'il doit beaucoup à William Leymergie
c'est vrai si l'énergie n'étrangle pas
Jean-Philippe Viaud Beccaro ne décroche
pas qu'un jour de boulot à France 2
autre mise à pied cette semaine Olivier
Minne son émission s'arrête alors qu'il
n'a buté personne nouvelle politique
France 2
Pascal Bataille convoqué au tribunal de
Bordeaux pour excès de vitesse pourrait
en cas de condamnations rejoindre très
vite la chaîne maintenant c'est casier
judiciaire obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
de consolation toutefois pour Olivier
Minne il produira trois comptes de 26
minutes jouées par des animateurs de
France Télévisions alors quelques idées
à lui soumettre strangulation blues avec
William Leymergie y a-t-il un pilote
dans l'avion avec Jean-Luc Delarue et il
castrato ou chasseur de noir avec Pascal
Sevran
[Applaudissements]
je vais l'enlever ça m'empêche de
ce qui a vécu Christopher
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors j'ai quand même fait tirer
une revue de presse mais très courte un
service minimum une info du journal auto
plus Nicolas Sarkozy a grillé 8 feu
rouge pris deux contre sens et franchi
une ligne blanche bon on est tous un
petit peu comme ça quand on reçoit une
lettre qui nous dit tu me manques j'ai
envie de toi viens vite
on fonce
Sarkozy toujours le Président remercie
son couturier en revanche pas un mot
pour son chaussures qui pourtant réalise
des prouesses
à Toulouse vente record pour des pièces
détachées du Concorde c'est fou ce que
ça a pris comme valeur il y a 7 ans à
Gonesse une pièce de concorde c'est
gratos
[Applaudissements]
c'est normal
l'élève dépasse son maître chroniqueur
en Saône-et-Loire deux enfants de
sans-papiers interdits de cantine par un
maire UMP c'est normal pas de bras pas
de chocolat pas de papier pas de purée
et à ce propos le Front National est au
bord de la faillite bah oui mais bon
Jean-Marie Le Pen aujourd'hui que Brice
Hortefeux lui a piqué son boulot que
voulez-vous qu'il fasse
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle accident mortel avec un chien
il s'agit d'un bébé chihuahua laissé
sans surveillance il aura fallu quelques
secondes à peine à Magloire pour le
bonheur
voilà
c'est fini désolé c'est court à la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu